على الجانب السياسيه حولت حرب اوكرانيا
ميزان القوه السياسيه شرقا تجاه بولندا
وبالامكان ملاحظه ذلك في الزياره التي
اجراها الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
بولندا للمره الثانيه
بينما لم يقم حتى الان باي زياره الى
حليفتي واشنطن باريس وبرلين في خطاب القاه
في وارسو يوم الثلاثاء اشاد الرئيس بايدن
بولندا ووصفها بانها واحده من اعظم حلفاء
الولايات المتحده مشيدا باحتضانها للاجئين
من اوكرانيا وبدورها الرئيس في الرد
الغربي الموحد على روسيا رئيس الوزراء
البولندي ماتيوش مراوشكي تفاخر بهذا الامر
تفاخر في مقابله قال فيها ان مركز الثقل
انتقل الى بولندا والى دول اخرى في وسط
وشرق اوروبا اشار موراسكي ايضا الى ان
بولندا لن يتم الحديث عنها بعد الان على
انها مجرد عضو عضو شرقي جديد في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفي النيتو وانه حتى يتم
الاستماع للصوت البولندي اكثر حول ما يجري
في المنطقه مع ذلك وفي حين يعترف بعض
الخبراء خبراء السياسه الخارجيه بان
بولندا اصبحت محورا الا انهم قلقون من
انها قد لا تكون جاهزه تماما وقت الازمات
بسبب المعارك السياسيه المحليه قبل
الانتخابات الوطنيه في الخريف يضاف الى
هذا الخلافات مع دول الجوار البولندي
ومنهم المانيا في بولندا الحزب الحاكم
القانون والعداله يعود لطرح ملف التعويضات
عن الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهي مساله
تعتبرها برلين مغلقه منذ فتره طويله وفي
هذا الصدد تصر بولندا على ان المانيا لا
تزال مدينه لها باكثر من تريليون دولار
بسبب المذابح التي تسببت فيها المانيا
النازيه الوضع الجيوسي في اوروبا تحدث عنه
تقرير
لبيوتربوراس مكتب وارسو التابع للمجلس
الاوروبي للعلاقات الخارجيه
قال ان على القاده البولنديين الحرص على
عدم المبالغه في استغلال الاعجاب في
اوروبا بدوري وارسو لانه من الممكن ان
يتحول بسهوله الى غضب والسبب التجاذبات
السياسيه الداخليه في بولندا
[موسيقى]